scientists are using mood drugs to help
adults learn new skills and improve
cognitive function let's look at some
info a Harvard professor used Danza peso
a drug that's typically used to treat
Alzheimer's to rewire the brain of a
visually impaired woman after using the
drug the woman was able to process
images the way a newborn would and
eventually regain normal sight he also
used an epilepsy drug called valproate
to teach tone deaf adults how to find
musical notes so this is pretty amazing
stuff and these are just two examples of
this kind of thing and there they
actually think that there's all kinds of
pills that they can give you that'll
legitimately make you smarter we did a
story on rewiring your brain last week
that the Internet is actually rewiring
our brains because we look at phones so
much are we going to have like as our
super humans on the way we always think
it's robots that are going to take over
but you know if enough medication is out
there to change the way we think and the
problem is always the side effects
because they always go oh great and then
they go but you know your times good I
got the moonwalk everybody like really I
got a moon water yeah I take that pill I
do love to root walk yeah but no it just
feels super creepy like take this pill
you'll hear sounds take this like it
just but also there's that whole thing
it says the pill helps adults learn as
fast as babies do and like I was like it
was talking about this whole cognitive
processing of babies how they process
information and I was like really I want
it it just seems like babies like I
don't like they're like they don't seem
extremely intelligent to me like they
don't I mean like but there I think it
took you you to walk yeah I'm like five
years for you to be like complete
sentence I mean how long is this pill
gonna take for me to like do the Rubik's
cubes yeah I think it's the rate that
they're learning considering they were
in just some money yeah I just feel like
you know if you're gonna take a bill to
rewire brain I would want it quicker
than like zero to four years yeah if you
could take a pill to be smarter so what
was that movie with DeNiro and yeah
with whatever whatever Bradley Cooper
Bradley again we did would you want to
take a pill of course what I would I
read those chemical again I have kids
and it said that you said like up to six
or seven they really retain a lot and
then I was like well I better start
getting some classes for these kid like
but they can of the piano lessons or
something you what it is I mean it would
be amazing if I if you could take a pill
and just retain everything is how many
times we like for example names touring
is a comedian how many times I've seen
somebody I'll be at a weekend at a club
and is keep running the manager and the
waitress in the man just I don't know
what their names are I need name tags
you know yeah you know it's it is it
just feels like that really it's a thing
with America you know what's wrong take
a pill you know you want to remember
something take a pill how about you read
a book Kabul you know I mean like it it
always seems to me like super it so it's
always the fast cut alright yeah but I
mean this study was really exciting
because it it would help people like
traumatic brain injuries so I'll give
you that but like some fat ass on a
couch like I can't remember anything I'm
going to start popping these pills right
so I am I will say to the camera I am
extrapolating a bit yes it was being
used for medical purposes and we're just
taking it to the next step there isn't
necessarily science behind all of this
but what part of the problem be that
only rich people would be or at least
wealthy people would be able to afford
this stuff and then you're gonna have
not just a divided by economics but
literally a smart divide yet proper it's
I mean hopefully if if this technology
ever came to fruition and everyone could
could partake in it but cuz that's how
everything works right yeah something
good happens everyone gets it without
but it's like I mean the unfortunately
you're right it's it's this pill culture
like you go oh just take a pill get
smarter and the unfortunate thing is we
don't put money towards education we
don't we don't uh help the poor you know
giving them opportunity in raising them
and and so you think I'll take a pill
you get smarter we have a capacity for
being smarter but now how are they gonna
get smarter if you know if you're not
teaching them it's it's very complicated
the whole thesis I got to take a pill
yeah things will be fine